we did four workshops on the final
workshop where we were presenting to
everybody at the studio at Fox we had
Peter Turner's company we had a number
of other people who were considering
investing in this and so there was about
80 people in this room we had an
eight-piece Orchestra we'd gone for two
weeks and I'd had a regular checkup
because I've had some problems with
minor skin cancers I went to have my
checkup go guys are you go on and you
got to get it out and I said ah I might
get it out in like a week because any
goes no Hugh this is cancer you're
getting yellow now so I got it out had
80 stitches in my nose and I said I'm
gonna go back to rehearsal I've gotta go
and sing you guys there's no scene you
can't sing the next couple of days I
said no you don't understand this has
been six years and we've got the final
presentation Toliver on I couldn't sing
we had someone a stunt singer to sing
for me and I read the part but when it
got to the final song I thought I'll
just sing the first line is quite so I
sing the first line and I seen the
second line I sing the third line before
I knew it I was singing the whole song
because that you Justin bends his music
is so and of course it's kind of a great
showbiz moment people thought I was
probably pretending that anyway until
they could see blood trickling so I had
to go and get them redone
[Music]
you
[Music]